[Musique]
il ne s'agit pas de donner aux gens de
l'herbe à fumer monde et s'est défoncé
d'ascendant notre université n'est pas
intéressé par l aîné
on s'est surtout penchée sur l'aspect
médicinales je suis une scientifique
dans le domaine de la santé une
formation de métier je suis très excité
quand tout cela parce que je vois le
potentiel pour la création de nouveaux
médicaments dans le monde daté moi c'est
ça mon intérêt les motiver nous avons
commencé à étudier comment le cannabis
pourrait être valorisée sur le président
à nouveau traiter certaines maladies ce
que les bcra est ce aussi parce qu'ils
ont toujours été un médicament
traditionnel
[Musique]
les grands-mères donnait du thé de ganja
aux enfants
si on souffrait d'une entorse on se
frottait avec une huile de cannabis
et il ya quelque chose dans le cannabis
et ça marche et si ça continue devant
chez moi je vais continuer à l'utiliser
à ce changement de loin de nos installe
l'autorisation légale d'utiliser la
marijuana on ne peut pas être poursuivi
pour la consommation pour son
utilisation religieuse est un droit
religieux maintenant pour les rastas
c'est la loi de ce pays
[Musique]